welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Boston a Mandalorian trailer was
released at d23 giving us our first look
at Jon Favreau Star Wars series on
Disney Plus Petra Pascal is starring as
the Mandalorian gunfighter in the days
after the fall of the Empire and
returned the Jedi but before the
emergence of the first order in the new
trilogy it's right that dirty sweet spot
that every Star Wars fan can agree was a
great time to be alive I'm gonna break
down this trailer for the details that
you might have missed what are you
saying yeah I did spoiler I said it so
many times they they know what I mean
you know what I mean
do they think you're not in this alright
let's get started
[Music]
cool damn so our first shot depicts a
pile of sand a stormtrooper helmet some
smeared and dried blood as a figure
walks by a row of more helmets on pikes
but yeah I'm guessing that it's not just
helmets probably severed heads in there
too don't forget
stormtroopers are people and some
stormtrooper has friends on these bikes
what a striking image to introduce this
Mandalorian post Empire world strong
troopers it looks like are being
executed and made an example of and
their helmets are being left on kind of
reminds me of the inglorious basterds
marking their Nazis with swastikas see
death doesn't exonerate space Nazis of
their colors either thus and the
background the bright sunlight harsh
shadows all kind of suggest that we
might be looking at Tatooine here but
then again Star Wars has a ton of desert
terrain planets including jakku Severine
so never judge a Star Wars planet by its
dirt I want to move on to the next clip
of the trailer but first thank you to
raid shadow legends for sponsoring this
episode
raid is the brand new free-to-play
collection RPG game with an amazing
fully voiced story campaign and over 400
champions across 16 heroic factions that
you can collect assemble and customize
just look how insanely good deliverable
detail is on these champions you got
this happy fellow look at those teeth
he's got a chunk missing from his ear
he's wearing an apron time to barbecue
look at the hair gel work going on
somebody's no stranger to mousse and I'm
loving the the Dwayne the rock Johnson
inspired tat work personally I've just
been enjoying making each of my heroes
more powerful leveling them all up I can
tweak things about them to make them my
friends who can never leave me now you
don't have to take it from this psycho
there are more than 200,000 reviews and
an almost perfect score in the Play
Store and raid is growing super fast
with almost 10 million players worldwide
who have downloaded the game in the past
three months so what are you waiting for
just go down to description click on
these special links to download raid and
you will instantly get 50,000 silver and
a 3 epic champion as part of the new
player program to start your journey
good luck we'll see you there alright
let's move on
okay let's clip the ship soars over a
forest terrain and the mandalorian
departs the shipyard into a town just a
background you can see a rolling
astromech droid sate Mandalorians come
from the planet Mandalore known for
their distinctive armor like the bounty
hunter Boba Fett's wore Mandalorian
armor in the days of the Old Republic
the Mandalorians were war mongers fierce
fighters they raided the Jedi Temple in
the years of the Clone Wars they're
actually overthrown by balls shadow
collective yes small is alive and well
in this storyline in the animated series
and actually in the live-action Canon as
well according to the end of solo Star
Wars story
gotta keep up with us like pretty much
everyone they were ruled by the Empire
but now the Empire's collapse the
Mandalorians may be scattered look at us
with this lone Mandalorian gunslinger
and bounty hunter Pedro Pascal who in a
close-up appears to be exchanging goods
with this man grief carga played by Carl
Weathers
got himself stew goin grief is the
leader of a bounty hunter guild who
hires a Mandalorian to track down some
valuable asset I'm guessing a person
it's always a person next clip
so the mandalorian ship flies over a
cracked canyon surface or maybe it's
over a colossal alien with very dry skin
close-ups show him slipping weapons in
his boots strapping on his gauntlets he
heads out for the day there's a shot of
Gina Carano
who's playing Cara dune described as a
former rebel shock trooper shock
troopers were the elite soldiers used by
various armies many of whom became
mercenaries because they're so badass
next is the shot of Mandalorian facing
an armed writer on a blurgh blurgh first
appeared and he walks the Battle of
Endor that was a made-for-tv movie and
I've shown up at Star Wars the Clone
Wars and then there's a winking Twilight
girl this she's twisting a dagger in her
hand I can't be certain but there's a
guy in front of her who looks like he's
the head of bill burr bill burr is
playing another character in this series
and before I move on there's an example
of some wonderful western inspired
imagery the director of photography for
this series the same person who did
rogue one so the imagery is fantastic
here we see a lone gunslinger walking
across the landscape it's the exact kind
of Shane and John Wayne inspired imagery
that George Lucas originally brought
into the first Star Wars let's move on
okay here the character played by I
think this is Emily swallow she hugs the
kid tightly in the water you can see a
piece of machinery beside them perhaps
they've crashed landed in this pond but
next there's a row of black armored
death troopers we actually saw these in
row 1
accompanying Critic I just love the D so
that the heat looks like it's burned off
the black paint on the tips of the
barrels of their weapons then another
example of classic Western imagery the
familiar gunslinger frame a close-up on
the Mandalorians hand as he grips his
blaster in its holster
apparently moments before draw this shot
was also used on Han Solo in the
original Star Wars and it's solo a Star
Wars story next we see Gus fring
Giancarlo Esposito is character he
appears to be leading in the empire
faction he's flanked by death troopers
on one side white armored stormtroopers
on the other and before we move on a
sick looking nighttime speeder bike
chase same kinds that the stormtroopers
chased him with on Endor in Return of
the Jedi and I think this is our one
shot in the trailer of Pascal without
his Mandalorian helmet on to the next
clip
bounty hunting is a complicated process
okay here there's a shot of an 80s tea
chicken Walker attacking an area with
defensive fortifications so we're
getting more examples of how even after
the death of the Emperor regional
governors and existing Empire factions
are still making the aftermath extremely
messy
the war is not completely over in a nice
neat little bow civilians fleet gunfire
and then there's a shot of the
Mandalorian blasting down a door with
his droid this is IG 11 and it's voiced
and mocap performed by Tyco with
teaching who is one of the directors of
the series as well there's a cool look
at space battle now the series is being
budgeted at about 15 million dollars in
episode so yeah you can expect some film
quality here then the Mandalorian fires
at turrets and IG eleven twists and
pivots kind of like a Rubik's Cube
behind back shot very nice and notice
how his head twists as well it's giving
him a 360-degree view there then the
Mandalorian finds himself surrounded in
a standoff with a squad of stormtroopers
and again great attention to the detail
here they're all covered with rust
colored dirt and then we hear the lovely
voice of Anna whom we meet in the final
clip
don't you agree bar fights always
appreciated the Mandalorian grabs his
dude by his freakin face tentacles
smashes them into the counter that's why
you always tuck those in and when he
tries to run Mandalorian lasas his foot
drags them back blast the door which
snaps shut probably discover this guy in
half not a good day also right beside
that door looks to be like a giant tusks
a Fang or a claw or something make me
wonder is this whole bar inside of a
giant skull or is that like a decorative
or construction material kind of looks
like it could be a rancor tooth or claw
next there's a creepy shot of a stack of
bounty the fugitives frozen in carbonite
exactly the way Han Solo was an empire
in Jedi apparently Darth Vader's whole
experiment of this being tried on Han
the fact that it was successful has led
to it being a common practice and then
the Mandalorian faces his character he
wears this interesting pendant with the
crest of the Empire on it this looks
like some kind of metal of Valor maybe
like the Empire equivalent of the medal
given to Luke in Han but not Chewie by
the rebellion at the end of Star Wars so
I'm thinking Herzog must be some kind of
Empire boy list comment down below with
what you're most looking forward to for
the Mandalorian follow me on twitter and
instagram at EA vas and subscribing to
rock stars for more breakdowns and
theories about everything Star Wars and
if you haven't already be sure to
subscribe to our Star Wars podcast feed
WikiLeaks for early access to audio
versions of all this stuff plus some
upcoming podcast exclusive content thank
you for joining me and I do not blame
Pedro Pascal for never wanting to take a
selling off we all remember what
happened only gave me thrust
[Music]